Darrin Revell ESPN sports business
reporter kind enough to join us here
Darren thanks for joining us
where did Puma come from that now all
the what is it now to with the hair 180
3.2 alright you got a lot of hair too if
I cut off that here you're about to
six-foot all right where did poha come
from here out of nowhere I they had
nobody seen other than Vince Carter you
know in the late 90s and you know after
99 he was gone and he went to 90 and
people forgot about them other than
Usain Bolt and they did nothing with
using both I mean they could have turned
that given how dynamic you say gold was
they could have turned some sort of
street shoe into the vault and you know
they never did they never capitalized
off him so it was only about three weeks
ago
that I heard these guys in Puma you know
they've been doing pretty well on
classic shoes they're ready to make a
splash in a basketball market the time
is right
one-ninety has everyone they want LeBron
Durant you know it Kyrie when he gets
back everyone they want but D this is
doing so well in the classics and you
know up 20% in 2017 so Under Armour is
almost completely out of the game by the
fact that they're struggling so this is
actually a good year to get big baller
Brandt is pretty much gone so this is a
good year to get in and they decided to
make a move
what about jay-z involved in the
creative control or whatever is official
title that was a disaster yesterday I
mean Google put out that he was the
president of Puma basketball and then
all of a sudden you know all these
agents are getting their undies in a
bunch and maybe rightfully so
the fact that he owns Roc Nation sports
one of his guys I'm science with Puma
and you know you wonder from NBA Players
Association standpoint to regulate
agents you
does it isn't considered an inducement
is it considered like okay well you know
it's come to me I'll wrap up the Puma
deal and by the way I'll get two or
three times the market value so that
immediately became a concern and then
five or six hours later I don't know act
tracking but you know I was talking to
two at Arak nation and they clearly said
in the contract it says creative
consultant creative director not
president of Puma basketball and you
know by the end of the night they're
like he does not have power but he is
going to be a creative force I still
don't think this is solved this is not
going to be the end of it most market
ability of the current NBA draft class
is who I think it's pretty young and I
also think because you know he seems to
fall out at the knick I think that
obviously makes it more so you know
Begley's getting a lot it's I mean I
don't think we have a slam-dunk but
certainly setting up for a young
obviously because so many people already
know him and if it just worked out to
the Knicks that that would be you know
something special as far as Madison
Avenue's concern talking to Darrin
Revell ESPN sports business reporter I'm
curious I mentioned this to the Dan
Hanson I don't I'm sure there's data on
this but are we more likely to buy a
shoe by somebody who is smaller
somebody our size or we relate ability
as opposed to Marvin Bagley and DeAndre
eight and selling Pumas is there any
data that backs that up yet yeah queer
clearly point point guard shooting
guards even forwards have better success
selling shoes the only person there's
only one Center I mean you including the
cell shooters the Olajuwon couldn't sell
shoes there's only one Center who saw
shoes and in that Shack now he wasn't
selling a ton of shoes when his his
Reeboks were called for a hundred bucks
in 1994 he was only starting to start to
sell maps that they're serious when it
yields a Casey penny and we're selling
them for 30
for a box sitting sold millions and
billions of pairs so yes it is more of a
challenge for a bigger guy to sell shoes
at a 80 to $90 plus price point simply
because people don't relate they see
themselves as six foot six one anything
that when they look at themselves they
see a crazy owner Steph Curry Nate okay
it's hard to relate to the big guys
Darren good catch up with you and thanks
for joining us as always we appreciate
it
Darren Orville ESPN Sports Business
Report for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]